[Music]
thank you
hello dear friends welcome to I'd like
to know one of our favorite programs
here at Secrets unsealed we're glad that
you decided to join us today we have
some very captivating questions and we
look forward to sharing the answers that
we found in our study of scripture first
of all I'd like to introduce my co-host
here Daniel Miranda who is associate
pastor of Fresno Central Church and he
comes here and he does I'd like to know
he preaches sermons he helps us out here
as well as Pastor gorea who is the
senior pastor of Fresno Central Church
we're glad that you're able to come and
help us with our programming uh welcome
to the program thank you it is a
pleasure for me to be in this program
and look forward to answering these
questions praise the Lord and we have
some very good ones today
before we actually have a word of prayer
to begin the program we do want to share
the address where you can send us your
questions the electron address it'll be
on the screen TV at some tv.org once
again TV at some
tv.org and I'd like to ask Pastor
Miranda if you would please pray that
the Lord will bless our program today
amen let us pray
dear heavenly father we thank you very
much for this new program of I like to
know today we have very captivating
questions as Pastor Bohr said and we
want to come reverently to the Bible
trying to answer these questions so we
pray that you may give us the wisdom and
the reverence and the solemnity as we
delve into scriptures we don't want to
twist the scriptures we want to stick to
what is revealed and we pray all this in
the name of Jesus Amen amen well uh the
first couple of questions were sent by
the same person I'm not going to mention
the name they have to do with the
godhead now in the past program we have
addressed this particular issue and
maybe uh Pastor if you could explain the
archiving system that we have here at
sequence unsealed yes so if you want to
check what questions have been answered
there are two ways of doing that one is
that you can go to the YouTube channels
some TV our secrets and sealed and there
you can find all the videos that have
been recorded on I like to know and
there is a description under the video
with the different questions that have
been answered but the easiest way is
actually downloading the app sum TV some
TV in the app you create an account for
free and then in the account once you
enter into the app you find the link to
other the episodes of I'd like to know
and with their respective questions in
that way you can refer back to the
different videos that have been recorded
thank you Pastor that's very helpful I'm
sure and I think a lot of people are
going to be checking out the app and
downloading the app and looking at all
the questions we've answered probably
hundreds of questions on this program so
it'll be very interesting to go through
all of them and find answers to
questions that people might have I
believe you've been doing this for more
than two years already right this
problem yeah we've been doing it
probably for about four years nice for a
little while there I did many of them by
myself because we didn't have you so
praise the Lord that you came on board
and very soon we're going to have
someone else who's coming on board who
is bilingual who is also going to be
helping us with I'd like to know as well
as sermons and many other very
interesting programs uh we'll announce
that uh in due time so the question is
in synthesis let's just say uh very
briefly uh uh what the godhead is and uh
and you know not repeat what we've uh
dedicated one whole program to in the
past okay
well Western Day Adventists we believe
in a uh in the godhead of not three
persons God the Father God the son and
God the Holy Spirit
that are co-eternal that have the same
nature and they're one in character in
nature in essence but there are three
distinct persons that's what we believe
as a seven day Adventist yes and um you
know Ellen White has made it very clear
that we should not try to Define exactly
what the holy spirit is and the Holy
Spirit seems to be in a special category
he's a person we know that uh you know
he uh he loves he can be uh he can be
offended right he can be lied to
Etc but Ellen White says that when it
comes to the Holy Spirit silence is
golden yes golden we can know a lot
about the fruit of the Holy Spirit we
can know a lot about the gifts of the
holy spirit about the impact of the Holy
Spirit but exactly Ellen White says what
the holy spirit is uh she says silence
is golden we should not get into that
territory
so anyway way now we have another
question what is the next question
you have something else on this one yes
on the same on the godhead the second
question so that's what you're referring
to okay I would like to make a comment
on here because the second is related to
the godhead
um but
it mentions and these are here a lot
that's why I want to make a comment that
Leroy if from
he changed the doctrine of the godhead
to the trinitarian doctrine in the
Adventist Church by changing statements
in the book evangelism to make her
appear that Ellen White was a
trinitarian
um you know I hear this argument and you
can actually go and write the white
estate
to confirm whether those statements are
original or not and actually
last semester I am doing uh some Masters
Dr um Graduate Studies online and that
Professor that we had actually dealt
with this issue in detail in history
exactly how it happened so there is
historical evidence that the
the Leroy from even though he was in
leadership position during the time that
the book evangelism was compiled he did
not put his hand in the compilation I
was actually the GC and in some
committees that were in church of that
but it was not him specifically
he had a lot of influence and changing
our christology yes but we won't get
into that right now right but in terms
of you know for example that statement
of Ellen White there are three living
persons in the Heavenly Trio I've seen
that statement in the handwriting of
Ellen White
It Was Written in her own handwriting
and so many of these statements can be
corroborated by the handwriting Bell and
white yes
um okay so now let's go to the next
question has to do with uh gender
inclusive language
so you want to share that with us okay
let me let me should I read it the whole
question go ahead and read it
um so the question
we're not going to to mention the name
either because it's a little bit
sensitive it says on this past Sabbath
worshiping from home I Came Upon your
internet program I like to know which
promoted some TB of which I was totally
unaware on the on the YouTube channel
and then he watched an episode and
there's it says that Passover responds
to a question about Christian women
wearing pants
that was the episode that he watched by
mentioning among other things the first
action of the
117th Congress to ban the use of a list
of words of in furtherance of gender
inclusiveness
some mention was also made of political
correctness
the rev the relevance completely escaped
me immediately I experienced cognitive
dissonance I admit that I was very
skeptical I decided that at the
appropriate time I will look into the
matter myself
and then he sends a link
so this has perplexed him he feels
distressed
and he would like some clarity in
regards to your statement about
political correctness and inclusiveness
gender inclusiveness okay I'm glad this
question came up because an explanation
is uh do
uh actually what happened was when
um the House of Representatives met for
the first time in January 15 2021
there was a move
to have in gender inclusive language
in the House of Representatives I have
an article here from uh this is from a
reliable news source
um
it's um well I don't know whether we can
share the specific uh the specific place
it comes from but
I just want to read a section of it the
title is remover of gender specific
terms from house rules does not amount
to a ban
okay so in other words gender inclusive
language gender specific terms was not
banned
but it was strongly encouraged I read
this article is by Ali Swenson January
15 2021.
claim house Speaker Nancy Pelosi called
herself a wife a mother a grandmother a
daughter on the floor of the House of
Representatives this week after Banning
that type of gender-specific language in
all House communications then this is
the aps this Associated Press assessment
uh this statement is missing context a
resolution passed in the house in early
January struck several gender-specific
terms from a document outlying house
rules in a move to honor all gender
identities the change did not ban lot
makers from using such language in floor
speeches or other Congressional
Communications so there was a suggested
ban
in the House of Representatives
but I suggested maybe not ban but it was
suggested that
um to honor all gender identities
house rules should uh
strongly recommend gender specific terms
uh to be struck
and that's uh that's what I really meant
in the program that is mentioned here in
this question now the person who sent
the question is really missing the point
uh you know there's a strong move that
we have seen since then
to require the use of uh
non-gender-specific language
in the media
also in Congress
and in other venues
in the name of equity in other words
because of equity you know we need to
eliminate gender distinctions so that
everybody feels comfortable that's
political correctness
I read a statement I think in that
program I haven't looked at the program
but I read a statement in that program
where Ellen White makes it very very
clear
that the dress
of women and men should be distinct one
from the other because the Bible teaches
that there are two genders that's right
the Bible does not teach that there's
only you know you're the gender of your
choice actually we should remind
ourselves I guess about that right I
know this is a very familiar passage but
it's good to read it
because we need to be very clear on this
in Genesis chapter 1
and verse
um
27 the Bible says so God created man in
his own image in the image of God he
created him male and female he created
them
so God created two genders that's right
male and female that's right and so the
point that I was trying to make is that
there's a tremendous move towards
political correctness when it comes to
gender
and that's gotten to the point where you
can't even say he to someone who
considers himself a she even though he
was born as a he uh you know because
that person might be offended well the
First Amendment to the Constitution
protects even offensive speech it does
not it does not allow for speech that
leads to violence but it does allow
offensive language you know in the early
history of the United States the
Constitutional period you know those
legislators really offended them one
another on the floor they used offensive
speech that doesn't mean that we can use
speech that causes violence but we can
use feet speech that might offend
someone
uh Ellen White made it very clear that
we're supposed to maintain the
distinction between male and female and
she's addressing specifically dress
this is selected messages Volume 2 page
478.
God designed that there should be a
plain distinction
between male and female dress
that would show that she's saying that
she should make a distinction between
male and female for male you should use
male pronouns and for female you should
use female pronouns
she continues God designed that there
should be a plain distinction between
male and female dress and is considered
the matter of sufficient importance to
give explicit directions in regard to it
the for the same dress worn by both
sexists would cause confusion and great
increase of crime we've seen that
Saint Paul would utter a rebuke were he
alive
and should behold females professing
godliness with this style of dress
and then she quotes scripture in like
manner also that women adorned
themselves in modest apparel with
shame-facedness and sobriety not with
broidered hair or gold or pearls or
costly array but which becometh women
professing godliness with good works the
massive professed Christians utterly
disregard the teachings of the Apostles
and wear gold pearls and costly array so
very clearly Ellen White states that
there should be a distinction between
male and female dress
and so that would show that Ellen White
clearly uh
said that we should make a distinction
between male and female gender that's
right
so I hope that this helps my point was
not uh to uh
was not primarily what the House of
Representatives did which suggested you
know strongly that not non-gender
specific language be used but my point
was that as Adventists we believe that
there's a clear distinction between male
and female amen
amen okay
um so do you have something additional
you want to say regarding this nope nope
I think it's clear okay well now let's
go to the next question which we might
say is closely related to the issue of
attire exactly I was actually going to
say that the last quote kind of helps
answer this question yes
this is a short question is it okay to
braid hair
for men and women and women yeah well
let's refer to the text that Ellen y
quoted in the last quote that you shared
this actually First Timothy chapter 2
verse 9.
First Timothy chapter 2 verse 9 I'm
reading from the new King James version
the Bible says in like manner also that
women Adorn themselves in modest apparel
we're propriety and moderation not with
braided hair or gold or perils or costly
clothing so here it says not with
braided hair
now the question is is the Apostle Paul
condemning
braiding your hair or what is what is it
actually saying here well the way I read
it is that he's talking against anything
that is in modest
improper that doesn't follow the rules
of Purity and modesty so that that's
what I see in this text
um actually uh I agree with you 100
percent actually I think what the
Apostle Paul is emphasizing is that
nothing should be done with the purpose
of attracting that is individuals to
ourselves that's right to exhibit
ourselves to show off ourselves
and you know in First Peter chapter 3 we
find a similar passage from Peter so
Peter and Paul are on the same page it
says in First Peter chapter three wives
likewise be submissive to your own
husbands that's very uh very much not
followed these days that even if some do
not obey the word they without a word
may be won by the conduct of their wives
when they observe your Chase conduct
accompanied by fear do not let your
adornment
be and it's interesting that King James
version adds the word merely it's not
there in the text
it says uh like this uh your Chase uh
let's see what uh okay verse two when
they observe your Chase conduct
accompanied by fear do not let your
adornment be
outward
arranging the hair wearing gold or
putting on fine Peril rather let it be
hint the hidden person of the heart with
The Incorruptible beauty of a gentile
gentle and quiet Spirit which is very
precious in the sight of God in other
words what should be attractive
is not what is on the outside
what should be attractive is what is on
the inside exactly
so um I think that's the principle
behind it I sometimes we need to be
careful not to fall into the extreme of
going into particulars right whether
saying well this is right this is wrong
uh God has given us a conscience and
conscience has to be enlightened with
the word of God to make the right
decisions now I know that some people
have some health reasons for not
braiding their hair and that's fine
that's respectable but we should not
make it a rule for everyone I mean some
I remember someone once said that that
it actually doesn't help the scalp and
that can produce headaches
apparently there's some medical evidence
I cannot give it but still that is to
the conscience of every person if
braiding the hair is normal braiding
doesn't it it's not showy it's not
attracting the attention I wouldn't see
any problem with that as long as it
follows the principles of the Bible so
in this program we're not going to say
it's wrong or right exactly to braid
your hair it's kind of like we what we
dealt with a Sabbath in a previous
program you know the scribes and
Pharisees they prescribed to the
minutest detail what you could do and
what you couldn't do uh you know the
question is what is your motivation
is your motivation to attract attention
to yourself to show off and not to bring
honor and glory to God by your
personality by your internal qualities
and the person has to be honest with
their own conscience in that case you
know we can't dictate why an individual
is braiding their hair or whatsoever
everyone has to render an account of
their motives and intentions to God Amen
not specifically to us amen I agree
okay now what is the next question the
next question is very long
and very scientific
so how can we synthesize this this next
it's actually mostly comment their
commentary rather than uh question
well the question has to do with
predictions in science and reasons for
these uh discoveries so the question one
says that there have been found that
there were nucleoided nucleoid bases
through chemical analysis of pristine
extraterrestrial material that have not
been significantly compromised by
terrestrial contamination
with this the theory of
Parts permia can be supported that the
proper meteorites compounds came to
Earth
to then undergo chemical evolution
so
um you know I've heard some of these
things before
and I don't think well none of us are
scientists so we cannot go into all the
scientific jargon in order to try to
understand these
but the Bible first of all is clear on
several things number one
we should only occupy on those things
that are related to our Salvation
there are certain details that even if
they're revealed in the word of God
are not necessarily
um how should I say this so that people
don't misunderstand me are not
necessarily salvational
there are certain even theological
things number two
everything that science
promotes or says we should test it by
the word of God in other words we don't
test the word of God
by science we test science by the word
of God and the word of God is very clear
in regards to life in other worlds
and also in regards to the origins of
our planet
so everything that goes beyond that like
saturation level the structural life
that we believe in is that beings that
have never fallen that are much more
beautiful than us and we believe we
don't believe in the theory of evolution
we believe in a a recent creation that
took place in seven literal days
So based on that then we can filter all
these information yeah
first verse of the Bible I think settles
the question yes yes
the beginning God
created the heavens and the Earth
and then it speaks about the seven days
of creation week
and we know that those days were literal
amen because the fourth Commandment says
that we're supposed to work six and rest
the seventh because God Worked six and
rest of the seven so how could God tell
us to work six and rest the seventh
following his example unless the
original days were literal days uh the
seven days were literal days
and science you know evolutionary
science tries to find all kinds of
explanations that contradict what the
Bible says but we are Bible Christians
amen and we believe the testimony of the
Bible
and uh and that settles it for us God
said it we believe it and that settles
it for us amen
very good that would be the the answer
that I could give that's the litmus test
unfortunately science
which Ellen White says science so-called
many times comes up with things that
seem to contradict scripture
and then a little bit later on after
further research they say oh oh you know
the Bible was right and uh and that
happens time and again it happens in
archeology too I remember when when they
said oh you know that idea that uh you
know that certain civilization existed
in Antiquity like Nineveh for example
and then of course Nineveh was dug up
and said oh oh and Nineveh did exist
after all and so many archaeological
discoveries have shed light on the
veracity of scripture and I think as
time goes by the Bible is proven also to
be scientifically uh correct amen amen
okay now the next question has to do
with the Sabbath
and this person
um
is very difficult to pronounce the name
williex Jacobi
I suspect well he's from Africa it says
from Malawi Africa yes and this person
quotes uh the fourth Commandment and
then uh men's makes this comment due to
the mode of payments we have in these
last days due to technology like PayPal
for example
does it make sense to refrain from
buying anything on the holy day except
buying electricity units or mobile
phones units on the Sabbath
so does technology negate
the Commandment not to buy or sell
basically is the question well that is a
good question and we want to answer it
thoroughly so we'll have to do that in
our next program because we're running
out of time so we really thank you
William for your question we promise
stay tuned wait for next program we are
going to try our best to answer your
question actually the first time that I
am asked this kind of question very
interesting question thank you for
sending it okay thank you for being with
us God bless you and remember to stay
tuned every week we have a new episode
of I'd like to know see you next time
God bless you
[Music]
foreign